This summer, in a place where no one feels safe. Every once in a while, a story comes along that fills your heart. Two brothers, one canoe. This Christmas, get ready to, oh my god, my voiceover alter egos are taking over my brain and I like it, I'd just be my self. Will Arnett here, welcome to an all-new smart list. I was about to say, Sean just told me in the middle of saying something I proposed and he told me to go fuck myself and here's right before we logged on and here's a reminder
me, I think I talked about this, I hate when people, when they do pictures and people give the finger in pictures, not funny, it's not interesting, it's not funny. People think like, hey, let's get a picture and then everybody goes fuck you. You know the only time it's funny is when little, little, tiny, tiny kids do it. I guess, but even. You know, I've got one of my favorite, favorite pictures, you both will appreciate this, is a picture of Jimmy Burroughs looking just dead into camera with those dead shark eyes and just a flaccid old finger right at me, right at the camera and it's one of my favorite
things. I know, but here's my point and obviously we love Jimmy. Jimmy Burroughs is a director of Lots of Sick Coms and. Every episode of Will and Grace, cheers. Cheers, cheers. I mean, he's done everything, but the message is what? Fuck you? I guess it's sort of like.
It's people thinking they're feeling catchy and they're feeling like, oh, it's a bonding thing and it's saying, hey, we're so close that I can do this. I think it's in a good spirit. I always take it it's in lieu of actually something funny. Did you just say lieu? He did. Beautiful pronunciation. In lieu.
In lieu. Can you just say lieu? You're saying and maybe they're, what if they're a little insecure about their ability to smile in an attractive way? Well then just say that. Well, sorry. Did you want to hang on a second? I think Will needs to burp, hang on.
If you just rotate your chin away from the microphone next time you have a bubble. One of the great things about you having difficulty signing on was I hammered my food before you got on because I thought, if he sees my fat face gorging out on this food, your face has been beautifully less fat lately. I really been, is that fight camp or are you sick? Either way, thank you. When people say like, you know, I had a customer once say to me, we were doing a fitting sort of mid show and she goes, Will, you can't get too skinny.
And I said, that's what I always say. You know, I ran down here this morning, I'm so embarrassed. I was on a phone call. I was running late for this. And so I'm like, I go, Scotty, can you just put my, can you hook up my computer? And he's like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So I come into where I usually sit right here in front of this computer. And it was like 30 seconds before we started and I screamed, I go, Scotty, Scotty.
He goes, yeah, I go, give me the plug, I don't have the plug. Like the, the, the power plug and he walks in and he goes, it's already plugged in. And I'm like, what? Very, in that very calm, your hysterical twit voice. But this is, I have, don't you guys have like a specific set up the way you have everything? Yeah. So he, he switched all my wires on all the opposite sides of my computer. Jason, you know, there's, there's, there's a sexual input joke here, Will.
I don't know if you want to take it. Go for it. Or you want, you want a moment to write that? We'll come back to it. No, no, no, I was going to, I was going to, I was not going to make a joke there, Jason. Because I'm respectful. I don't know if you'll get me. No, me too.
That's why I wasn't going to make it. I'm very respectful. I don't even think it's funny. Hey gang, to me, there is no better human moment than when you hear someone or see someone that you immediately feel a connection to. Sometimes that's in person, but at other times it's at an audience distance. When you hear a song they write or a performance they create or an interview you watch or a book they write, you get the sense that that person may tick like you and they put that
similarity into words or action in a way that you never could. This next guest is one of those people. He is a writer and his talent in articulating his thoughts is matched only by his enormous curiosity and intelligence. He has written articles and books on many subjects covering sports, finance, and most recently the pandemic. Some of his books have even become some of our favorite movies such as The Blindside, Money Ball, and The Big Short.
Oh my God. Friends, please welcome the big brain, Michael Lewis. Oh wow. Kidding. There we are. Good morning. Hello there. Hello there.
So cool to meet you. I'm so, so happy you are doing this with us, sir. We had a brief chance to talk a few months ago and it was one of the greatest conversations I have had that I'm not exaggerating. I'm not puffing there. It was great. So thank you for coming on and sharing your head and your thoughts with us. No, it's a total gas.
I can't believe that what I just heard. Is anyone listening? Well, I just wonder what's left. Like, yeah. It was great. Michael, I've read a number of your books. So this is such a thrill to meet you and what I love about your books is that you hone in on subjects that are kind of right there in front of us, right under our nose.
But you offer a perspective that you say, hey, look, this is right here, but actually look at what's happening. So let's say we'll take the blind side, for instance, I didn't understand anything. You know, I watched football my whole life. I didn't understand the importance of the left tackle. And now, of course, people in football would, but you, you honed in on this idea of the left tackle. And then you brought this, you told it through the lens of this, this young man who was an
incredible talent at left tackle, the money ball, you told it, you know, you, you talked about what Billy Bean was doing up in the Oakland athletics. And then you taught, told it through the lens of a guy who was a kind of a renegade who was amongst GMs and outlier, if you will, because he approached the game differently. At a certain point, he changed the way he looked at the game. All of your books seem to hone in again on these ideas of, you know, things, subjects that are right there, but you find a different angle on it. What, how, A, how do you find these stories and B, what, what sort of leads you towards
these kinds of stories? Let me give you a couple, I'll give you a couple examples, because it is, it's a really undisciplined process that is, it's not like a formula. And every time I finish one, I think I'll never find one again, because it just, it just, everyone's seen, felt so sui generis, like you just, you just not repeatable. By the way, by the way, not to interrupt, well, to interrupt you, but I just to let you know, every time I finish one of your books, I always think, well, that's it, there's no way Mechalooze is going to find another story like this that is so surprising.
I'm not kidding you. And then every time I get your newest book and I always go, wow, how surprising. So the two examples you mentioned, so Moneyball, I just, we'd been living in Europe for a couple of years. I hadn't watched American sports in forever. We came back and I flipped on the television and the Oakland A's were playing. And I was watching and listening to the announcers. And I noticed, I mean, this was what, 2001, and salaries exploded.
And I noticed that the left fielder was like being paid $6 million a year and the right fielder was being paid 150 grand. And I thought, I wonder how pissed off the right fielder is when the left fielder drops a fly ball. And that was like sort of like, is there class resentment on a baseball, they're now social classes on the baseball field because you've got these people getting paid so much money. And so I started watching just the money on the field. I would stop watching it, like the money, just try to see if they hated each other because
of the money. And I couldn't detect anything. But then when you start looking at the money, you start to realize that, whoa, it's not that it's the players. It's like the Yankees have $150 million to spend on players and the A's have like 30. How are they even competing? And why are the A's winning as much as the Yankees? And so that gets you to a question you want an answer to, right?
That doesn't make any sense. In a normal, if this is a market, it's a free market for baseball players, you would think that the team that has the most money would just buy all the best ones and just win all the time. And that wasn't happening. So I called up Billy Bean to ask him this question. I went and went to see him. And I didn't know it was going to be a book.
I thought, I didn't know it was going to be any more than a conversation. I was just kind of curious. And that day, I walked to his office, I asked him the question. He said, no one has asked me that question. And it's what I spend my life thinking about. He says, the sports writers aren't interested in anything but like the sports. And you're asking me about the money. And what we think about is like, how do you value these people?
So then I thought, wow, you know, this is kind of cool that I'm looking at the game in the way the person who's trying to manage one of these teams is looking at the game. How do you make it? What's the story? And then it's gumbo. It's like you need these ingredients. And so the fact that, you know, it takes a while to get it out of him that Billy Bean kind of has a motive that he has, he was misvalued by baseball coming out of high school.
They thought he was going to be this stud and he drafted him in the first round and dissuaded him from going to Stanford and he hated him for it ever since because he never really panned out. He really wished he'd been, his life had been disrupted by baseball's inability to understand the players. But the moment, there's like a moment. I can remember there's like a moment where I said, all right, this is a book. It was like six weeks into it.
And I was interviewing the players because the A's were obviously doing these things that other teams weren't doing. They had like a fat guy leading off and they had a guy playing first base who'd never played first base and half of them looked like a beer league softball team. And I just thought like, what are the players, like the players know they don't look like other teams. And how do they feel about that? So I was moving down the cubbies in the locker room.
Each day I'd take a different player. And this was like one day I was going to go see a player. It was after a game. I'm waiting for him at his cubby. And I was watching the A's come out of the showers and it was the first time I saw the Oakland A's naked. It's like, I never like watched. And it was the most appalling sight.
It was just, it was like, there's like fat ankles. They were just like, it just, and I thought, if you line those naked bodies up against the wall and ask anybody what they did for a living, they'd say, like, I don't know, are they certified public accounts? Right. They would never guess they were professional athletes. Let me just say to the CPAs out there and cool it with the responses to what Michael said.
Okay. Right. So, so I think I go to the front office and I said, you know, I know this is going to sound out, but I was just watching your guys naked and, and they don't look like athletes. They don't look like anything. And the guy in the number two played by Jonah Hill in the movie said to me, you know, that's kind of the point. You know, we've been using better analysis and better data to figure out who's actually
doing what on a baseball field and what it's worth. And when you find like people who are much better than the market knows they are, the kind of players we need, if we're going to win because we can get them cheap, usually there's something wrong with them that they usually look wrong because if they look right, everybody knows they're valuable. And I think they look like a stud baseball player. People are looking for a stud baseball player. If they look like our guys, like people say, nah, he can't, he can't, and he started going
down the list. They had a guy with two club feet, he was a pitcher with two club feet, which is, and they said, you know, people wouldn't hire him because he couldn't move very well. The ball was hitting near him, but the club foot actually imparted this weird spin on his screwball that that's, so it was like one thing after another. And I thought, oh my God, this is gold because it's no longer, it's no longer just baseball, right? It's like, all right, they're building a juggernaut out of, out of misfit toys that out of people
down the list. They had a guy with two club feet, he was a pitcher with two club feet, which is, and they said, you know, people wouldn't hire him because he couldn't move very well. The ball was hitting near him, but the club foot actually imparted this weird spin on his screwball that that's, so it was like one thing after another. And I thought, oh my god, this is gold because it's no longer, it's no longer just baseball, right? It's like, all right, they're building a juggernaut out of, out of misfit toys that out of people
who nobody's seen the value in, and forget it's baseball. Think of it as like a business that you've got all these guys doing their job, same job for a hundred years, people watch them on the job, millions of people watch them on the job, their stats attached to every move they make on the baseball field. If that person, that employee can be misvalued, who can't be? Right. So they're in line, the, the sort of relatability, the evergreen thing that you thought would lend itself to something for mass consumption, not just baseball fans.
So yeah, a stupid question, like, is the right fielder pissed off at the left fielder when he drops a fly ball, led me down a rabbit hole to a place where I had another, I had an observation that I thought, wow, this is an important observation. But also you've kind of honed in on, there's like an underdog element, I don't know if it's underdog, but it's people who are succeeding in whatever field, whatever their discipline is, almost against convention. And are you drawn to that? And I think in a lot of your books, that element exists, you know, people who are doing it,
who don't seem like, like, if you were to look at Sean, you know, you'd be like, there's no way that he's going to be successful, you know, look at him, he's barely sitting upright. You wouldn't think like comedy, you might think romantically, you know, he's just miscast. He didn't even know his computer was plugged in this morning and it was right in front of him. His husband had to tell him. But wait a minute, Michael, for dumbass me who knows nothing, what is it like now?
Do people, because I don't know about any of this stuff, how do they put a price on it now knowing all of this information on each player? Well, you're much less likely to be undervalued if you're homely or misshapen. People now see beneath the surface, you know, in baseball now, but I don't think, but baseball, you know, it's a, it's a little lab, it's a, it's a very orderly universe where it's very easy statistically to assign credit and blame and figure out who did it. It's not like in life. Yeah.
Most of life is much harder. Yeah. So it's just telling you that in life, this stuff is going on too. And it's very hard to, it's much harder to see below this. What made you become like obsessed with finance and money and like want to explore all facets of it? Because I, I am too, I think, you know, when, when you're lucky enough like me or us or whatever to have made a few extra bucks in your life because you got, I got lucky, and you know,
most Americans, most citizens don't have the time, energy, resources, anything to learn about or educate themselves about how money works because they have families, they gotta go to work, they come on, you know, so once you start to force yourself to learn a little bit about it, you go, wow, this is really complicated. It's almost like it's, it's built on purpose to be complicated to keep everybody confused. It is built on purpose to be complicated. What got me interested in it was, I mean, I think it was an odd thing because this is the beginning of my career.
You have a degree in economics, don't you? Yeah. Yeah. But I have a half-assed degree in economics. That's not half-assed. And he worked at Solomon Brothers and. Yeah, you worked at Solomon Brothers. That's right.
Yeah. But that's what I was going to say. I grew up in New Orleans. Right. And I grew up in this culture. I call it Nolans. Nolans. Sorry.
That was, it was a really strange place to grow up. It was like, it was not like the rest of the United States. There's a line that, to understand New Orleans, you have to stop thinking of it as the southern most city in North America and start thinking of it as the northern most city in South America. And it really was, it was, it was not a, it was not a successful place. It was like, it was in permanent decline and people define themselves not by what they did or how much money they made. It was really like family.
And it was, but it was pretty happy. Like it was like, and when I left, I was shocked when I went east to college. I was shocked by the connection between success and unhappiness. I would not have put it that way at the time, but like there are all these people who came from New York money, who are all these kids in my class who are going to go to work on Wall Street and, and they were kind of miserable. And, and, and I didn't even see the value of it. Like what is this Wall Street thing that everybody's obsessing about?
I was an art history major in college. At the end of my college career, I thought, actually the world is a conspiracy of people who speak this language that Sean is so popular by. I got to go learn the language. I didn't know what I was going to do in my, so I went and got a master's degree at the London School of Economics and got a job on Wall Street and I'm writing about it. What I think would drew me to it was that original feeling like there's some, something screwed up about American culture and the epicenter of the screwed upness is this place.
And I'm going to understand this place and, and then, you know, I mean, I, my first book was Liars, called Liars, Poker, it was this little memoir of me working on Wall Street. Which is, by the way, being made into a film now, right? It's always being made into a film and never being made into a film. It's one of those things. So it's, Warner Brothers bought it and it's been sitting inside of Warner Brothers for, you know, 30 years. We'll get it made.
We're going to, after the interview, we're going to make some calls. But let me ask you this. So, so I would imagine at that time when you went to, when you worked at Salomon Brothers and you went to an Ivy League school, those, that people who were in, in that sort of world, whose parents worked in finance and, and then they went and worked in finance. And now, of course, we have an entire, talked about class in the baseball field. We have an entire class of financiers, especially on the coast, Los Angeles and New York. If you want to send your kid to school, you got to, it used to be, you had to be worried
about sending your kid and be worried about, you know, showbiz people, too many showbiz people at your school. Now it's too many finance people and they're, they're kind of everywhere and they've dominated and of course they've, there's lots of stories, of course they've, you know, increased the gap between the haves and the have-nots and there are all these people who have ridiculous wealth. Were you ever worried seeing those people, especially with a, with a art history degree, do you have a healthy dislike for people in finance and for the, and for the kids, and
for kids who are, who have now are in the position where they have inherited or are about to inherit vast sums of wealth and have no discernible talent for anything. And cause this is something that's, we used to call them gold card, you know, Rastas or whatever back in the day. And now these kids, there's an entire class of people who don't know how to do anything and they're given everything. You must be exposed to lots of that. So I have been throughout my life, but it's case by case basis.
Some of people are great and some people aren't. It's a, but it's a, it's a really goofy system. And that's the thing that is sort of despicable is the system and the system revealed itself to me immediately because like you get a degree in economics. You don't know anything about money. You don't, you don't know like what to do in the stock market or you don't, you just, that's not what they teach you in economics. It's much more what theory?
It's theory. Yes. And so I didn't know anything about money. And within 18 months, I was being paid hundreds of thousands of dollars a year to talk people into doing things with money that they shouldn't have been doing. And professionals, I mean, like they're not, not moms and pops, but people who are managing hundreds of millions of dollars. And it was clear I had no value to the world, like probably negative value to the world.
I was getting people to do things they probably shouldn't do half the time. And we made money by moving the money around. And it was that, that original observation is like, there's no connection between what I'm extracting for myself and what I'm putting in. Like I'm not, I'm not being rewarded for making the society a better place for adding value to the society. I'm just, I'm like, just like taking rents out of the economy. And I think that is a pretty good description of much of Wall Street.
And what's happened is it's just grown and grown and grown. That it's, when I got there in the late 1980s, the Wall Street was, you know, twice as big as it had been in the generation before as in relation to the rest of the economy. It's now twice as big now as what, than it was then. And so that it's become this machine, the other thing about it was, like the Wall Street, there was a thing about old Wall Street where the kind of people who went to work there were either sort of the C students at Yale, not so bright, but like, you know, everybody thought they were a nice guy, or, you know, Vinny from Staten Island, who had
a high school diploma, and Vinny could do really well. It was a way, it was a kind of partly an engine for social mobility. And now it's become, you have to be so highly credentialed up front. Are you wearing underwear? I'm wearing shorts. Listen. Oh my God. I'm wearing shorts.
Listen, that's what we're going to get. That's your next. Sorry, sorry. Sorry. You just like flashed me in the middle of. Yeah. It's a lot of thigh. Well, there we go.
It's a lot of thigh. All right. So, but that, now it's sort of like you need your physics degree from MIT to go work at Wall Street. And the kind of, it is not an engine for, for social mobility. It's kind of an engine for ossifying the existing social relations. Rich kids get to go to Harvard, Princeton, Yale, and then they go to the Wall Street firm where they get paid a lot of money doing things that aren't really very useful for
everybody else. And you want to know why our politics are that way they are. A lot of people are justifiably pissed off. Yeah. Of course. And you have people, right. All those kids, they graduate and they all get, they all become associates at Goldman or wherever and they get fed into that machine.
And I think you're right. That used to be a thing. I guess those guys, people who would come in as, you know, you, you call, you said sort of the guy from Staten Island, whatever that, those were the people who were the traders on the floor, right? The class system within Wall Street that existed. They're gone. They're gone.
Wall Street is, oh yeah, they're all gone. The machines have eliminated their jobs. Right. Right. So you, and so, so now it's MIT and now you're creating the perfect black box of the thing that's going to predict what the market does, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. Or the thing that's going to rape you when you go into the stock market to do your trade. Right.
The most efficient. Right. It's not all bad. No, no. There's a lot of dandies out there keeping, keeping up the good side of the ledger. We got a good guy. There's a good guy we know. There we go.
Dandies. He's a friend of the podcast. We'll be right back. Back to the show. Michael, so, you know, you touched, we touched on just the politics of it. I'm always fascinated with, well, I'll just cut to the chase and ask the question. What is your prediction in the next election? How will affect finances?
Because I'm always fascinated about how that works. It seems like every election cycle, something happens where, you know, it goes up or down or something shifts kind of like glacially, but it happens. You seem susceptible to hearing false wisdom. Oh, thank you. It's nice meeting you too. You're asking me to tell you something no one knows. You said that nicer than Will and I ever have to know.
No, no. It's really, it's such a sweet question because you're sort of like, oh, you must know. Yeah, right. I know you don't know, but I know nobody knows, but I like to hear people's opinions and predictions anyway. No, no, no, no, no. I think it's fascinating how elections affect money. Yeah.
Is it sort of the common thought that, you know, to oversimplify things, if Republicans are in stock market goes up, if Democrats are in stock market goes down, but hang on a minute because if it goes up with the Republican side, it may burst. The Democratic, it may go down, but at least it's a true down and it'll slowly creep up in a legitimate way. Can I answer a different way? Yes, please. I think it's sort of like a train that's on a track and it's not going to go off the
track unless there's a big catastrophe. And I think there's one, so I mean, like the market, the market is just, in the end, what it is, is giving you your little percentage of corporate earnings. And I don't really see forces in our society that are going to undermine corporate earnings. It seems like those, the forces for corporate earnings, political, et cetera, keep getting stronger and stronger, unless there's a revolution of some sort, some sort of, so I can imagine that happen in a couple of ways. But the way I think about, like the one thing I watch and think about, oh, I've ought to
take my money out of the market if that starts to happen is the solvency of the country. Like will the U.S. government honor its debts? Like, do you trust the treasury? Do you trust these things called treasury bonds? Because the whole global financial system is premised on treasury bonds, U.S. treasury bonds being viewed as a riskless asset. But what do you think about that, the idea of the myth of the deficit? Did you read that book?
I just got it. What's your name? I haven't. It's not a myth. Okay. So yeah. So I haven't read the book, but I understand that we can print as much money as we want to pay off our debts.
But this is a matter of faith, that if the Chinese government decides that, oh, and other governments, that we're not going to actually pay back our debts and they don't want to hold these pieces of paper, there's a vicious cycle that would kick in. And what I kind of imagined Trump was going to do, and he never did it, because our debts never really became a huge problem. We haven't got the point where we're cutting federal programs because we need to serve us to the debt. But that's not that far away, that if I would imagine Trump was going to get up and say,
you know, who do we owe this money to? We owe it to the Chinese of $2 trillion of these pieces of paper. How do they get that? Raw trade deals. We're just not going to pay them back. The minute you start to whisper that kind of thing, or the minute the society proves incapable of handling its finances, that's when I would start to think, I'm not sure about this.
But to answer your question, like, what's going to happen? I got no idea. And I don't actually... And that's our time. I don't actually take action based on, like, some future events that are unpredictable. Let me ask you your opinion about this thing. There's this interesting article about, you know, when you talk about the corporate earnings and the debt, it's potentially sort of the lifeblood of this country and how we maintain,
you know, health and to be, quote, unquote, number one in the world and all that stuff. They were talking about the existential risk and crisis of what is potentially happening right now, which is everybody kind of quitting their job because of the... Everyone kind of got used to being able to live with a little bit less and not chasing, you know, not on the hamster wheel as much through the pandemic because everyone was home. And the article went on to kind of talk about how what if people stopped buying into this race for dog eat dog and being better than your neighbor and this capitalism sort of
你知道的，健康以及——引用的话——成为世界第一之类的。他们当时在讨论当前可能正在发生的这种生存风险和危机，也就是每个人似乎都因为……大家在疫情期间都待在家里的经历，开始习惯了生活需求少一点，不再去追求那些，你知道的，不那么像仓鼠转轮一样拼命了。那篇文章接着讨论了，如果人们不再买账这种人吃人的竞争、不再盲目追求比邻居优秀以及这种资本主义
rushed to acquire everything and to be the richest and have the most bling and all the creature comforts and all that. What if people started living a little bit more like some of the number two or number three countries, you know, that take all of August off and they have these four-day work weeks and they just like... You're talking about Denmark or France or any of these other places that are comfortable not being number one there because they're older and more mature and they're not like trying to show off and like what if America just kind of found that place and all the
争先恐后地获取一切、当首富、追求最多浮夸装饰、所有物质享受等等，会怎么样呢。如果人们开始活得更像某些第二或第三梯队国家的人，你知道的，他们整个八月都在休假，实行四天工作制，他们只是……你说的就是丹麦或法国或任何其他这些地方，他们觉得当不上第一也挺舒服，因为他们更老成、更成熟，并不想刻意炫耀。如果美国也能找到那种状态，然后所有的
corporations were like, uh-oh, they're not buying it anymore, that they need to be better than their neighbor. I think about that all the time. So it was like that's something a big brain like yours could probably really get your arms around and write a really compelling book about just everybody kind of going, yeah, we're good with less and what would the corporations do about that? Are you pitching me a book idea or asking me a question? Can we talk offline about that, please?
大公司都觉得：呃哦，他们不再买账了，不再觉得非要比邻居优秀不可了。我无时无刻不在思考这一点。所以这就像是一个像你这样的大脑真正能够理解，并写出一本非常引人入胜的、关于大家觉得“少一点也挺好，而大公司会对此作何反应”的书的题材。你是在向我推销一本书的创意还是在问我问题？我们能私下谈谈这个吗，拜托？
So, you know, what I was hearing you say is what if America became a sane place instead of the moronic inferno? And it's, I don't know, can our culture change that much? Maybe, one of the things that is happening that is sort of maybe behind all this is demographic change, right, that the new people coming into the workforce, it's smaller numbers than we've seen forever compared to the size of it. So the reason you're going to see kind of a tilt, I think, in negotiating power towards employees is they're fewer of them.
所以呢，我听到的你的意思是，如果美国变成一个理智的地方，而不是一个痴呆的地狱，会怎么样？而且，我不知道，我们的文化真的能改变那么大吗？也许吧，正在发生且可以说是这一切背后推动因素的事情之一，就是人口结构的变化，对吧，进入劳动力市场的新人，与整体规模相比，数量比我们以往任何时候都要少。所以你会看到，我认为，谈判筹码向员工倾斜的原因，正是因为他们人数变少了。
That seems to be kind of happening and maybe, yeah, I'm all four. So this gets back to how people lived in New Orleans. So American materialism, when I collided with it for the first time, just shocked me. It jolted me because I hadn't really grown up with it and it seemed so unhappy. Don't come between us and our stuff. I remember once seeing a documentary about a guy and he followed, I forgot what it was called and his parents were immigrants, I think, from Hungary and his dad hadn't been back there in sort of 30 years, this is maybe in the 80s or 90s, anyway.
这似乎正在发生，也许吧，我完全赞同。这就回到了新奥尔良人们的生活方式。所以美国的物质主义，当我第一次与之碰撞时，简直震惊了我。它震动了我，因为我成长过程中并没有真正接触过它，而且它看起来是那么的不快乐。别挡在我们和我们的物质之间。我记得有一次看过一部关于一个男人的纪录片，他跟踪拍摄——我忘了它叫什么了——他的父母是移民，好像来自匈牙利，他爸爸大概有30年没回去了，这大概是在80年代或90年代吧，总之。
He goes back to Hungary with his dad and his dad sees his family there and they all sit out and they have this huge meal outside. And he starts talking to his family and his dad's crying with his brothers and the extended family, et cetera, and they interviews his dad after the dinner and he says, how is it being back? What's the difference? What I forgot, he says, when I'm in America, people say, what do you do? But when I'm back here, people, the first thing they say is, are you happy?
他和他爸爸一起回到了匈牙利，他爸爸见到了那里的家人，大家坐在一起，在户外享用了一顿丰盛的大餐。他开始和家人交谈，他爸爸和兄弟们以及大家庭等等抱头痛哭，晚餐后采访了他爸爸，他问：“回来感觉怎么样？有什么不同？”我忘了，他回答说：“当我在美国时，人们会问：‘你是做什么的？’但当我回到这里时，人们问的第一句话是：‘你过得开心吗？’”
And that's the difference. And I think that that's a cultural, Jason, to answer your question, I don't know, I'm not answering it, but my sort of feeling on that is there needs to be a major cultural shift and it's something that doesn't necessarily exist in this country and frankly, never has. I mean, you look at New York, you look at these places, they were built on this idea of trade and always at the heart of it. Michael, I'm not telling you anything you don't know, famously New York didn't have a lot of great churches because it wasn't a religious center, which at the time was
这就是区别。我认为这是一种文化上的差异，杰森，为了回答你的问题——其实我并没有直接回答，但我对此的某种感觉是，这里需要一场重大的文化变革，而这在这个国家并不一定存在，坦白说，从来就没有过。我的意思是，看看纽约，看看这些地方，它们就是建立在贸易的理念之上，而且贸易始终是核心。迈克尔，我没有告诉你任何你不知道的事情，众所周知，纽约并没有很多伟大的教堂，因为它不是一个宗教中心，这在当时
unusual for a founding of a new city. They were always, that was kind of the centerpiece. New York wasn't about that. It was always about trade, it was always about commerce and that is at the heart of the, when people talk about the American idea, they always talk about getting ahead, getting all the things you want. And it's about degree, but the white picket fence, the house, all that stuff is stuff. Yeah.
对于一个新城市的创立来说是不寻常的。它们总是，那曾经是核心。纽约可不是为了那个。它一直关乎贸易，一直关乎商业，而这正是人们谈论美国理念时的核心所在——人们总是谈论出人头地、得到你想要的一切。这关乎程度，但白色的栅栏、房子，所有这些东西，都只是物质。是的。
I wonder if it's still just sort of like a long tail to the fact that we're young and that we're just starting out and we're trying to prove it to the world that this country can make it. We're only, what, a few hundred years old. I mean, there's, you can buy cigarettes in a building that's 600 years old and in any part you know. I'm very young. That should be, sorry, this is an aside, but I'm very young.
我在想，这是否仍然只是因为我们还很年轻，我们才刚刚起步，我们正试图向世界证明这个国家能成功，这只是一种长尾效应。我们才，什么来着，几百年的历史。我的意思是，你可以在一个有600年历史的建筑里买到香烟，无论你在哪个地方，你知道的。我很年轻。那应该是，抱歉，这是题外话，但我很年轻。
Still anyway, that's, I guess, watch this space. We'll see how our country does. Change directions for once. Your podcast against the rules is in its third season now. And so with this, do you have, you really like exploring these subjects more deeper, more fully through conversation as opposed to kind of just with your singular prism of just you in front of a screen typing away. Tell me about that.
无论如何，那，我想，拭目以待吧。我们看看我们的国家会表现如何。破天荒地改变一下方向。你的播客《对规矩说不》（Against the Rules）现在已经出到第三季了。带着这个，你是不是真的很喜欢通过对话比单纯通过坐在屏幕前埋头打字的单一棱镜更深入、更全面地探讨这些主题。跟我聊聊这个吧。
The answer that is no, because it's not like this. It's crafted storytelling that it's essentially taking my magazine life into audio. And what interested me was audio. It was the different kind of muscle you have to use with an audience when you're writing for the ear as opposed to on the page, and I just wanted to see what that felt like. And I felt like from the beginning of my career, I found that was after I finished a book, the best thing to do was not write another book and find something else to do. And what I used to do is write screenplays.
对这个问题的回答是“不”，因为这可不一样。这是精心雕琢的叙事，它本质上是将我的杂志生涯搬进了音频世界。而吸引我的正是音频。当你为耳朵写作而不是为纸面写作时，你必须对受众使用的肌肉是完全不同的，我只是想体验一下那种感觉。而且我觉得，从我职业生涯的一开始，我就发现，写完一本书后，最好的做法不是再写一本书，而是去找点别的事情做。我以前常做的事是写剧本。
And that was, it was almost like, like literary cross training that, you know, I'd spent all this time running marathons and I was going to take the off season swimming and lifting weights. It was just like a different thing. You were using different muscles. And I wasn't very good at it, but even though I wasn't very good at it, the kind of the nature of the medium, how compressed it is, how you're forced to visualize what you're putting on the page, which you're not when you're writing just prose, it just, it brings
那几乎就像是文学上的交叉训练，你知道的，我花了所有这些时间跑马拉松，然后我要把休赛期用来游泳和举重。这只是完全不同的事情。你在锻炼不同的肌肉。而且我并不擅长它，尽管我不擅长，但这种媒介的本质——它是如何被压缩的，你是如何被迫去将你写在纸上的内容视觉化（而你单纯写散文时则不需要这样做）——它确实能带出
something out. It improves you in ways. And so I did the podcast in the first place just to see if it would do the same kind of thing. And the nice thing about the podcast is that you don't need really anybody to make it. I mean, you get, it goes out there and it's been an education, how different the form is and what are the kinds of things that rewards a writer for doing. And it's, it's fed back into the books like the screenplays have.
一些东西。它在某些方面提升了你。所以我一开始做这个播客只是为了看看它是否能起到同样的作用。而播客的好处在于，制作它你实际上不需要任何人。我的意思是，你把它发布出去，这真是一场教育，让人了解到这种形式有多么不同，以及它对一个作家有哪些回报。它反哺了书籍，就像剧本曾经做的那样。
It's made, I think it's made me just a better prose writer. And so one of the things that you're exploring with the podcast is the subject of expertise, like the sort of the notion of how many things can you really be expert at, great at, how many should you try to be great at, or should you just focus on one or two things in your whole life or, or, or is everyone just sort of spreading themselves too thin and they should just focus on not your lane, but I don't know if there's this sort of the sense of too much ambition maybe in this world or I don't know, help me out. What interested me in this subject was sort of like the status of the expert.
我认为它让我成了一个更好的散文作家。所以你在播客中探索的主题之一就是“专业性”这个课题，比如关于一个人究竟能真正精通多少事情、在多少事情上做到卓越，你应该努力在多少事情上做到卓越，还是说你的一生应该只专注一两件事，或者说大家是不是都把精力分得太散了，他们应该专注于——倒不一定是你的领域，但我不知道这世上是不是有一种雄心过头的倾向，或者我不知道，帮帮我。我对这个主题感兴趣的是专家的地位问题。
What is, what's happened to that person in our society that the pandemic is like an incredible example of the problem that there was like a smart way to approach the pandemic. There were people who actually knew what to do. We never access them and, and we still to this day kind of people don't know who they are. And the kind of question was like, why are we, this country has this unbelievable ability to generate expertise, knowledge that, that there are, we lead the world in Nobel prizes. We, you know, the government, the US government filled with people who know more about some
在我们的社会里，那个群体究竟怎么了？大流行就是一个绝佳的例子，暴露出这样的问题：其实有一种明智的方法来应对疫情，有那么些人实际上知道该做什么，但我们从未联系过他们，而且直到今天，人们仍然不知道他们是谁。当时的问题有点像：为什么我们这个国家拥有如此令人难以置信的产生专业知识和知识的能力，我们在诺贝尔奖获得者人数上领先世界，你知道的，美国政府里到处都是比世界上任何人都更了解某些
subject than anyone in the world. Sean knows the fastest route to Chin Chin from every point in Los Angeles. Can I pick something up? Yeah. Okay. Can I give you, I'll give you one example. This is one of the episodes. Yeah.
主题的人。肖恩知道从洛杉矶各个地方去秦秦餐馆的最快路线。我可以拿点东西吗？可以。好的。我可以举个例子吗？这是其中一集的内容。可以。
I have a friend, his name is Max Steyer. He runs something called the partnership for public service, who's, and he's trying to fix the US government in a nonpartisan way, just trying to like make it work better. And he figured out that one of the problems is the morale of the employees, because every time they do something bad, they're like publicly humiliated. Every time they do something good, nobody notices. So he tried to create a kind of Oscars like a, create an award for really good government, federal government workers.
我有个朋友，名叫马克斯·施泰尔（Max Stayer）。他负责运营一个叫“公共服务伙伴关系”（Partnership for Public Service）的机构，他正试图以一种无党派的方式修复美国政府，仅仅是想让它运转得更好。他发现问题之一是员工的士气，因为他们每次做了一件坏事，就会当众受辱；每次做好事，却没人注意到。所以他试图设立一种类似奥斯卡奖的机制，为表现极其优秀的政府和联邦政府工作人员设立一个奖项。
Calls it the Sammys. Nobody's paying any attention to it, but he's managed to get like thousands of people nominated for the Sammys. And he was reading to me to this, for this list of his Sammy Award nominees one day. And I realized like, what this really is, is a list of unbelievable experts. Everybody on this list has done something extraordinary with a very narrow expertise that would bore you to tears if you had to listen to it for very long. I said, but I want to take, so what in the show, I want to take one of these and just
他将其命名为“萨米奖”（Sammys）。根本没人关注它，但他已经成功让几千人获得了萨米奖的提名。有一天，他在为了这个节目向我朗读他的一份萨米奖提名名单。我意识到，这其实是一份令人难以置信的专家名单。名单上的每个人都在某个非常狭窄的专业领域里做出了非凡的成就，如果你不得不听很长时间，绝对会无聊得让你流泪。我说，但我想要采取——所以在这个节目里，我要挑选其中一个，来
to sort of dramatize how we aren't valuing, how we don't even know this sort of stuff exists. So randomly off this list, I picked the guy who was, he was just, it was an alphabetical order who was at the top. His name was Arthur A. Allen. And but Arthur A. Allen had done in his career in the Coast Guard as an oceanographer, was figure out how objects drift at sea. So if you fall off a boat, you know, if any of you fall off a boat in the middle of the
戏剧化地展现我们是如何不珍视、甚至根本不知道这类事物的存在的。我从这个名单上随机挑选了一个人，按字母顺序排在最上面的人。他的名字叫亚瑟·A·艾伦（Arthur A. Allen）。而亚瑟·A·艾伦在他的海岸警卫队海洋学家职业生涯中所做的事，就是搞清楚物体在海面上是如何漂移的。所以如果你从船上掉下去，你知道的，如果你在海洋中央
ocean. But one of you will say, but you, you will all float in slightly different ways. And you'll float in a different way if you're on a capsized sailboat or if you're on a raft or you're in a life preserver. No one had ever bothered to try to figure out how different objects drift at sea. Arthur Allen had watched some people die when he early in his career, book a mom and their little girl die on the Chesapeake Bay because they, the Coast Guard couldn't figure out how the boat they were on was drifting when it was lost.
从船上掉下去的话。但你们每个人都会说，不过你们落水时的浮动方式会略有不同。如果你在一艘倾覆的帆船上、或者在木筏上、或者穿着救生衣，你的浮动方式就会不同。过去从来没有人费心去弄清楚不同的物体在海面上是如何漂移的。亚瑟·艾伦在他职业生涯的早期看过一些人死去，切萨皮克湾有一位母亲和她们的小女孩死去，因为海岸警卫队无法弄清楚她们所在的船只在失踪时是如何漂移的。
And he said, I'm going to figure this out and spent 15 years dropping objects into the Long Island Sound in his free time, measuring how these things drift and, and, and putting it into mathematical equations so the Coast Guard could identify where you might be if they knew where you started. So in the history of like, of, of people lost at sea, nobody was up until very recently. Nobody even bothered to look for them because once you were lost at sea, you were lost at sea. Like we, the US government doesn't even bother thinking about this until World War II and
他说：“我要把这个搞清楚。”于是他在闲暇时花了15年时间将各种物体投入长岛海湾，测量这些东西是如何漂移的，并将之转化为数学方程，这样海岸警卫队如果知道了你的出发点，就能确定你可能在哪里。所以在海难失踪人员的历史上，直到最近以前，根本没有人甚至费心去寻找他们，因为一旦你在海上失踪了，你就是在大海里失踪了。比如我们，美国政府甚至懒得去考虑这个问题，直到二战时
pilots are shot down over the Pacific Ocean and even then they're not very good at it. It sounds like something I was almost going to do, but I just got super busy. So in 2007, he's finally finished his work. He's taught all the Coast Guard search and rescue people about how objects drift. A few weeks later, a 350 pound man runs out of his cruise ship window 75 miles off the coast of Florida into the Atlantic Ocean, like, and they don't discover he's gone for hours. They when they realize he's gone, they can look at the ship cameras and figure out where
飞行员在太平洋上空被击落，即便在那时，他们这方面做得也不是很好。听起来像是我差点就要做的事，但我实在是太忙了。所以在2007年，他终于完成了这项工作。他把海岸警卫队所有的搜救人员都培训了一遍，教他们物体是如何漂移的。几周后，一个350磅重的胖子在距离佛罗里达海岸75英里的地方，从游轮窗户跳进大西洋里，而且几个小时后他们才发现他不见了。当他们意识到他不见了时，可以查看游轮监控并算出他是什么时候
he went over. But normally again, they would, you know, a person in the ocean and you would just never bother. But this guy's equations led them right to where he was in the ocean. They pluck him out of the ocean. And since then, thousands of people have been similarly like rescued at sea because of what this guy did. That's crazy.
掉下去的。但通常来说，又是那样，一个落入大海的人，你根本不会去费心寻找。但这个家伙的方程直接把他们带到了他在海里的位置。他们把他从海里捞了上来。从那以后，成千上万的人由于这个家伙所做的事而在海上得到了类似的救援。这太疯狂了。
Wow. So, so, so one of our episodes is, the episode is just an example and this is a little, this is, it means it's sort of like written stuff, but it's the story of this guy, Arthur Allen, and this other guy, another fat guy who went off the boat of a fishing boat off the coast to 14 miles off the coast of Los Angeles. And eight hours later, they find this guy. And this guy, the question is sort of like, do we understand what we just did? Like, but in fact, there are no articles about Art Allen.
哇。所以，所以，所以我们的其中一集节目是，这集仅仅是一个例子，而这有点，这意味着它有点像写好的东西，但这就是这个叫亚瑟·艾伦的家伙的故事，以及另一个家伙的故事——另一个胖子，在距离洛杉矶海岸14英里的地方从一艘渔船上落水了。八个小时后，他们找到了这个人。而这个人，问题有点像：我们明白我们刚刚做了什么吗？但事实上，没有任何关于阿特·艾伦的文章。
There's no, no newspaper articles about how they did it, sort of like a miracle. They found a guy and the guy himself who's pulled out of the water. When you ask him what happened, he says, it was a miracle. I found Jesus while I was on the water and God saved me. So it's sort of like, this is just one of the episodes, an example of like how we don't get our minds around the value of the expertise we've created. Like we're incredibly good. Did Arthur win the Sammy?
没有任何报纸文章报道他们是如何做到的，这简直像个奇迹。他们找到了一个人，而那个从水里捞出来的人自己呢？当你问他发生了什么时，他说：“这是一个奇迹。我在水上时找到了耶稣，上帝拯救了我。”所以这有点像，这只是其中一集，一个关于我们如何无法真正理解我们所创造的专业知识的价值的例子。我们是如此难以置信地优秀。亚瑟赢得萨米奖了吗？
Really dumb with that. Did Arthur? And he didn't even win a Sammy. He didn't even win a Sammy. Oh God. He got beat by someone else. There's a guy, the guy on the cruise ship, he had like 50 Sammys and then, let me ask you, and then, and when they, by the way,
真够蠢的。亚瑟赢了吗？他甚至都没赢得萨米奖。他连个萨米奖都没赢。天哪。他被别人打败了。有一个人，那个游轮上的家伙，他拿了大概50个萨米奖，然后，让我问你，然后，当他们，顺便说一句，
It's also, it's also a good, a good word for where your tax dollars go, you know, like you never, you never realize, well, I'm paying all this money. This goes right into again, where we started, which is like you are finding kind of finding value where it has not been assigned properly is obviously something that interests you. And I think it is such a great sort of. Well, you stay curious, which is so great. And you did an incredible example of this with the premonition, right? But the expertise is the, the experts you found there and followed them.
这也是，这也是对你的纳税去向的一个很好的证明，你知道的，就像你从来不会意识到，噢，我交了这么多钱。这又回到了我们开始的地方，也就是你正在寻找那种尚未被正确赋予价值的地方，这显然是你感兴趣的事，而且我认为这真是一种极好的……。嗯，你保持着好奇心，这太棒了。你在《大难临头》（The Premonition）里就做了一个不可思议的例子，对吧？但专业性就是——你在那里找到的专家并追踪了他们。
I mean, for, you know, the listeners out there that aren't familiar with the, with the book, the concept of it, the subject matter of it, speak just a little bit about that, please. As an exercise, it was, it was a little different for me because I realized before the, even the pandemic happened, I realized that like the best things I'd done were character driven. And it was where I, and where I was weak in the books I'd written, where the books felt weak was where I didn't have a character who was, who could quite hold the story. And it was, and that the idea is kind of overwhelm the story. So I thought, next book I do, I'm just going to go find the characters and let the story
我的意思是，对于，你知道的，那些对这本书、这个概念以及它的主题并不熟悉的听众来说，请稍微谈谈这一点吧。作为一次练习，对我来说这有点不同，因为我在大流行发生之前就意识到，我做过的最好的事情都是以人物为主导的。这就是我的强项，而在我写过的书中，那些感觉薄弱的地方，恰恰是我没有一个能够真正撑起故事的人物。这就是，而且构思有点压过了故事。所以我想，我写下一本书时，我就去找人物，让故事顺其自然。
take care of itself. I didn't know what it was going to be about. And then the pandemic starts. And the thing, and it was a question in the beginning of the pandemic, like four months in, five months in, there was this stat that remains stable up until the time we had vaccines. And it was that the United States had fewer than 5% of the population in the world and we had more than 20% of the deaths. And at the same time, there had been like a ranking done at the cost of millions of
我当时并不知道它会是关于什么的。然后大流行开始了。而那件事，在大流行初期曾是一个问题，在大约四个月、五个月的时候，有一个统计数字在直到我们拥有疫苗之前一直保持稳定，那就是美国拥有世界上不到5%的人口，却占了超过20%的死亡人数。与此同时，在大流行之前，曾有人花费数百万美元和进行了大量研究进行了一项排名，评估每个国家对大流行的准备情况。
dollars and lots of research before the pandemic of how prepared each country was for a pandemic. And the United States came out number one. So it was like the Texas Longhorns ranked number one in the beginning of the football season and they went 0 and 11. It was like the preseason, it was something really wrong about our understanding of ourselves and our ability to deal with this particular threat. So I thought, I'm going to try to figure out not the pandemic because it's going to go on forever.
而美国名列第一。这就好比德克萨斯长角牛队在橄榄球赛季开始时排名第一，结果却打出了0胜11负。这就像季前赛一样，我们对自己的认知以及我们应对这一特定威胁的能力，存在着某种非常严重的问题。所以我想，我要试着弄清楚的不是大流行本身，因为它会没完没了地持续下去。我要写的是我们是如何把通往大流行的一切都搞砸的，究竟发生了什么，让我们本该如此优秀？我们显然拥有比任何人都多的资源。
I'm going to write about like how we screwed up all leading into the pandemic, like what happened that we were supposed to be so good? We obviously had more resources than anybody. And it went so badly at the price of hundreds and hundreds of thousands of American lives. If we just performed as well as like the average G8 country, several hundred thousand people would be alive now who are dead. But I did it with like, okay, I'm going to find characters and they have to be obviously relevant to the story, but I'm going to start with people I'm just interested in and I'm
结果却搞得一团糟，代价是成千上万美国人的生命。如果我们能表现得像G8国家的平均水平一样好，现在有几十万人就不会死，他们还活着。但我是这样做的：好吧，我要寻找人物，他们显然必须与故事相关，但我会从我感兴趣的人开始，而且只有当我找到我感兴趣的人时，我才会写一本书。这花了一些时间，但那本书核心的三个人是我写过的最棒的三个角色。而且他们都是无名之辈。我的意思是，举个简单的例子，查瑞蒂·迪恩（Charity Dean）是一名地方公共卫生官员，过去20年来一直在基层与疾病作斗争，不过让我把她先放一边，因为最容易描述的那个人是为美国撰写了大流行计划的人，他基本上发明了一种如何应对大流行的理念。
only going to write a book if I find people I'm interested in. And it took a while, but the three people who were at the center of that book are the three best characters I've ever, I've ever had. And they are like unknowns. I mean, like one quick example, I mean, Charity Dean is a local public health officer who has been like fighting disease on the ground for the last 20 years, who let me leave her to one side because the guy who's easiest to describe is the guy who wrote the pandemic plan for the United States, who invented basically an idea, an idea of how to respond
他的名字叫卡特·梅舍（Carter Mesher）。他整个职业生涯都是一名重症监护室（ICU）医生。他非常擅长——他说他有点多动症，他注意力不集中。他可以说是勉强混过了医科学校，但当他置身于生死攸关、必须高度专注的境地时，他却表现得极其出色。他是一位才华横溢的ICU医生，在退伍军人事务部一步步晋升到管理整家医院，并被布什政府选中来回答这样一个问题：
to a pandemic. And his name is Carter Mesher. He was a ICU doctor by his whole career. He was really good at, he said he had like ADHD, he doesn't pay attention. He kind of had to fake his way through medical school, but when he got in a place in a situation where life or death really had to focus, he was really good. And he was a brilliant ICU doctor who had risen up in the veterans administration to run whole hospitals and had been plucked by the Bush administration to answer the question
如果我们遭遇大流行，该怎么办？布什，乔治·布什曾饱受卡特里娜飓风、伊拉克战争的创伤，他还有9·11事件。他遭遇了所有这些烂事。他读了一本关于1918年流感大流行的书。他说：“我们的流感大流行计划是什么？”他们告诉他我们没有。所以他说：“去找一些能够拼凑出一个大流行计划的人来。”他们请来的人之一就是这位卡特·梅舍医生。
like, what do we do if there's a pandemic? Bush, George Bush had been traumatized by Katrina, Iraq, he had like 9-11. He had all these bad things going on. And he read a book about the 1918 influenza pandemic. And he said, what's our pandemic plan? And they told him we don't have one. So he said, find some people who can put together a pandemic plan. And one of these people they bring in is this Dr. Carter Mesher.
梅舍开始——当时有一种传统观点认为，在获得疫苗之前，你什么也做不了。所有那些，比如保持社交距离的尝试、他们所说的非药物干预措施、关闭学校，所有这些在1918年都没有起作用。而他就是不相信。他回过头去查看，重构了1918年的历史。他去查看：不同的城市发生了什么？死了多少人？
And Mesher starts to, there's a conventional wisdom at the time that until you get a vaccine, you can't do anything. That all the, like the attempt to like social distance, what they call non-pharmaceutical interventions, closing schools, all that stuff didn't work in 1918. And he just doesn't believe it. And he goes back and looks, he recreates the history of 1918. He goes and looks like, what happened in different cities? How many people died?
他们尝试做了什么？他发现，圣路易斯的死亡率只有费城的一半左右。但圣路易斯实际上确实采取了一些行动，比如在病毒到来之前更早地保持距离。他彻底改变了世界对你在初期应该做什么的看法。他与同事设法将这一点写进了一项计划，说服疾控中心（CDC）将该计划采纳为官方计划。疾控中心说服了世界其他地方，其实你们关于社会
What did they try to do? And he figures out that like, St. Louis had, you know, half the death rate of Philadelphia. But St. Louis actually did do things like distance earlier in relation to the arrival of virus. He completely changes the world's opinion about what you should do in the beginning. Manages with colleagues to write it into a plan, persuades the CDC to adopt the plan as the official plan. The CDC persuades the rest of the world that actually all your kind of beliefs about social
距离的各种信念都是错误的。尽管大流行降临了，这些真理是无可争议的，如果你问澳大利亚——澳大利亚会告诉你他们是怎么做得这么好、怎么保住人们性命的——他们会说：“我们使用的是美国的计划。”我们自己却没有使用我们自己的计划，它并没有像在其他地方那样被广泛接受。这一切都归结于这一个人，他有一种对拯救人类生命的执着，这种执着是在ICU中发展和培养出来的。
distancing are wrong. And although along comes a pandemic and these truths are uncontroversial and like Australia, you asked Australia, like how they've done so well, how they've kept people alive. They said, we use the US plan. We ourselves didn't use our own plan. It was not, had not been accepted in the way it had been accepted other places. Not all tracks back to this one guy who has this passion for saving human life that he developed and cultivated in ICUs.
所以我觉得，我找到了我们为什么会成为一个管理不善的团队的根源，为什么我们是一支才华横溢却在事情发生时表现不佳的队伍，并围绕这些人物构建了这本书，这真是太爽了。我的意思是，这样说可能很可怕，但我写过最有趣的书其实是一本关于大流行的书，它确实是我写过最有趣的书。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。迈克尔，我只想让你现在就为我们朗读你的新书。
And I, so I found like, I found like the seeds of why, why we were a mismanaged team, like why we were this really talented team that just didn't perform well once the thing happened and built it around these characters and it was a total gas. I mean, it's horrible to say, but it was like the most fun book I ever wrote was a book about the pandemic, but it was the most fun book I ever wrote. We will be right back. And now back to the show. Michael, I just want you to read, read us your new book right now.
就读给我们听。我就会坐在这里。我要空出这一整天的时间，只为了听你朗读。好让你强调对的词。太让人着迷了。对。对。真是太棒了，老兄。
Just to us. I'll just sit here. I'm going to block out the day just to have you read it. So you emphasize the right words. It's so mesmerized. Yeah. Yeah. It's so, so good, man.
我太喜欢了。没错。完全正确。但正如你所知，对于受众来说，正如你所想象的那样，要让人想读一本关于大流行的书是非常困难的。有趣的是，你传达信息的时间点和传达信息的内容一样重要。有些书的时机非常好，而有些书的时机则烂透了。
I love it. Right. Exactly. But as you like, you all have knows for like audiences. As you can imagine, it's very hard to get people to want to read a book about the pandemic. It's been interesting that you, when you deliver a message is as important as what the message is. And some books have really good timing and some books have really shitty time.
嗯，何时以及如何，你知道的，那是什么，而且你，同样地，你是通过那个故事的镜头、通过那个家伙——梅舍医生的故事来讲述的，这太迷人了。多么迷人的人物啊，一个，你知道的，而且你，你知道的，你说过这一切都是在大流行之前完成的。所以这就有点摆脱了任何政治影响等等。它就是它本身。他只是根据前一次大流行的事实简单地做他的工作。我认为这本书，如果我没记错的话，是另一本
Well, when and when and how also, you know, what it is, and you, again, you're telling it the story through the lens of that story of that guy that Dr. Mesher is fascinating. What a fascinating figure, a guy who, you know, and you, you know, and you said that he's all of this was done pre-pandemic. So there's, so it's kind of void of any political influence, et cetera. It's just, it is what it is. He's just simply doing his job based on, you know, the facts of a previous pandemic. And I think that this, this book, if I'm, if I'm right, is, is a, is another one that's
可能要被搬上大银幕的作品。所以那些像我一样不擅长阅读的人可能会有机会体验它。这是真的吗？它可能会被拍成电影吗？你比我更清楚这一点，但没有人知道一本书是否会被改编成电影。是的。
possibly headed to the, to the, to the big screen. And so those who are not great at reading like myself might have a chance to experience it. Is that, is that true? Is it, is it headed for a movie, perhaps? So you know this better than I do, but nobody knows whether a book is going to be turned into a movie. Yes.
环球影业买下了它。是的。他们说他们要把它拍成电影。是的。它有更多的——有趣的是。我的意思是，从买下版权到拍成电影，《点球成金》（Moneyball）花了七年时间。《弱点》（The Blind Side）当时没有人想拍那部电影，它之所以能拍成，纯粹是因为联邦快递的董事长弗雷德·史密斯（Fred Smith）说：“我就住在孟菲斯那个故事发生地的隔壁。”
Universal bought it. Yes. They say they're going to make it. Yeah. It's got more, it's funny. I mean, like Moneyball took seven years between the time they bought it. The blind side, nobody wanted to make that movie, and they only got made because Fred Smith, the chairman of federal express said, I live next door to that story of Memphis.
这个故事太棒了，不拍成电影说不过去，我们一定要把这部电影拍出来。所以我觉得这部作品背后拥有和我以往任何作品一样强大的势头，但谁知道呢。是的。而且你一直很有福气，有那么多伟大的电影人和编剧来接手你的素材。我猜你对影视化的恐惧在一定程度上被他们的才华所缓解了，还是说你根本不担心这个？
And I was too good a story not to get made and we're going to make that movie. But so this, I think this is kind of as much momentum behind it as anything I've ever had, but who knows. Yeah. And you've been so blessed with such great filmmakers and screenwriters that are taking on your material. I imagine that your fear of execution is somewhat mitigated by their talent or do you even worry about that?
对于他们用你的媒介以及他们在他们的媒介中对你的IP想做的事，全由他们决定？还是说你喜欢参与其中并试图保持它的质量、视角、主题，还是你直接就当甩手掌柜了？这真的很有趣，作者与电影之间的这种关系。的确，我觉得这是真的，总的来说，电影制作人其实更希望作者已经死了。一个活着的作者简直就是个累赘。
Have they done your medium and whatever they want to do in their medium with your IP is up to them? Or do you like to be in there and try to maintain its quality, its perspective, its themes, or you just kind of, you sign off? It's really funny, this relationship between the author and the movie. It's true that, I think it's true, that on balance, movie makers would much prefer the author to be dead. A living author is just like a nuisance.
他们满脑子想的都是：这家伙、这个作者会到处跑，说他们毁了我的艺术品之类的。而我从一开始就认为，我是最不适合把这个我创作的东西拆解并重新组装成其他东西的人，我做出了太多我所依恋的决定，而为了让电影拍得好看，这些决定必须被打破，必须由一个思路完全清新的人进来全盘接管。有趣的是，我对接手这些项目的每一位导演都这么说过。
All they're thinking is like, this guy, the author's going to run around saying they ruin my work of art, that kind of stuff. And I took the view right from the beginning that I'm the least well suited to take this thing that I made and break it and remake it into something else, that I made too many decisions that I'm wedded to that need to be undone for a movie to be any good, that someone as fresh as is going to have to come in and just own it. And what's funny is, I've said that to each of the directors who've taken the projects on.
拍《弱点》的约翰·李·汉考克（John Lee Hancock）、拍《点球成金》的贝尼特·米勒（Bennett Miller）、拍《大空头》（The Big Short）的亚当·麦凯（Adam McKay）。但在每一种情况下，他们都拒绝相信我。他们会说：“行吧，行吧，他嘴上说他不想跟这事沾边，全权交给我，但我才不信呢。”所以每一次都会上演这样一种舞蹈仪式，他们假装对我要说的话感兴趣，并征求我对如何拍好这部电影的看法。而我则不得不假装相信他们是真的感兴趣。
John Lee Hancock with the blind side, Bennett Miller with Moneyball, Adam McKay with the big short. And in each case, they refuse to believe me. They're like, yeah, yeah, he's saying that he doesn't want anything to do with it and it's all mine, but I don't believe it. So there's this dance ritual that's happened in each case where they pretend to be interested in what I have to say and solicit my views about how to do the thing. And I have to pretend to believe that they're interested.
这完全是个谎言，根本没人对我要说的话感兴趣，我心里也清楚。但“你无法从一个谎言中建立起一段伟大的关系”并不是真的，我爱这些人，虽然这段关系的开始方式完全是不诚实的。所以我最终和所有把这些作品拍成电影的人都成了朋友，尽管我对这部电影是怎么拍出来的没有任何影响。而且我认为这种模式真的行之有效，因为除此之外，如果你说服他们让他们拥有所有权，他们也会对这种所有权产生敬畏——如果拍砸了那是他们的错。
And it's a total lie, like nobody's interested in anything, I have to say, and I know it. But it's not true that you can't build a great relationship out of a lie, that I love these people and the relationship started in a completely holy dishonest way. So I've kind of gotten to be friends with all the people who have made the stuff without having any influence whatsoever on how the thing got made. And it's been, I think it really works that way because among other things, if you persuade them that they have ownership, they also have the fear of the ownership, like it's their fault if it sucks.
这与我无关，书就是书。而且我不——这是否能缓解我的担忧？我有过难以置信的经历，对吧？在这些电影拍得有多好这一点上，我幸运得难以置信。而且我对——我可以说是零恐惧，最糟糕的结果也不过是拍了一部烂片。这不会对书造成任何伤害，它不过就是一部烂片而已。嗯，你谦虚地认为他们可能对你要说的话不感兴趣，但我认为你错了，而且你在我们和我的面前绝对是错的。特别是接下来这个话题，在我让你离开之前，我想让你，你知道的，在
It's not my fault, the book's the book. And I don't, you know, does it mitigate, I have had unbelievable experiences, right? I've been unbelievably lucky in how good these movies have been. And I have, I do have kind of zero fear that, but the worst they can do is make a bad movie. That won't do any damage to the book, just like it'd be a bad movie. Well, you humbly say that they may not be interested in what you have to say, but I think you're wrong and you're certainly wrong with us and with me. And particularly in this next subject, before I let you go, I want you to, you know, in
我的开场白里，我谈到了你阐述复杂思想和主题的独特能力。我听你在安德鲁·沙利文（Andrew Sullivan）的播客上讨论悲伤。我简直被深深地震撼了，你如此慷慨地分享了你和你的妻子塔比莎（Tabitha）经历的悲剧——你们失去了女儿迪克西（Dixie），还有你的男朋友罗斯·舒尔茨（Ross Schultz），以及整个国家和世界在这次大流行中经历的所有悲伤。我只是在想，你是否可以与这个播客的听众分享一些你们可能经历过的关于悲伤的洞察和发现，这些或许能对他们有所
my intro, I talked about your unique ability to articulate complicated thoughts and subjects. And I heard you discuss grief on Andrew Sullivan's podcast. And I was just knocked out by how incredibly generous you were with sharing the tragedy that you and your wife, Tabitha, have gone through with the loss of your daughter, Dixie, your boyfriend, Ross Schultz, with all the grief that the country and the world are experiencing through this pandemic. I was just wondering if you could share with this podcast audience some of the insights, the discoveries about grief that you guys have perhaps experienced that might be of some
帮助，因为听你讲述简直太惊艳了。当然。我只想顺着这个话题再多说一点，我的思绪并没有什么特别的结构。女儿迪克西19岁，罗斯20岁，他们去年五月在一场车祸中丧生。他们真的是不可思议的孩子。在迪克西去世后，我有过几次顿悟，这听起来可能会很糟糕。
help to them, because it was just amazing to hear. Sure. I'm just going to lather on a little bit about this, without any particular structure to my thoughts. Daughter Dixie was 19 and Ross was 20 and they were killed in automobile crash last May. Just like incredible kids. And I had a couple of realizations after Dixie died, and this is going to sound awful.
但其中之一是，没有人真正能帮到我——虽然真正能帮到我的是我的社区的爱和朋友们的爱。他们在这个意义上可以帮你。但没有人经历过你所经历的一切，那是一种如此独特的体验。它与你和失去的那个人之间的关系息息相关。它与你对生死的情感息息相关。它与他们离去的方式息息相关。
But one is there was no one who could really help me in that it does what does help me is the love of my community and love of friends. They can help you in that sense. But there's nobody who's gone through what you've gone through that it's such a particular experience. It's so particular to your relationship with the person you lost. It's so particular to your feelings about death and life. It's so particular to the way they died.
当时有很多人，很多人来到我面前告诉我：“噢，我也经历过同样的事，以下是你将要感受到的，或是以下是你将要经历的。”他们都是出于好意。我不介意，但我发现，这些从来都不是真的。举个例子，许多失去孩子的父母说：“你将永远带着负罪感生活下去。”这可不是你应该对任何人说的话，但这就像是他们对与孩子关系中的某些事情怀有负罪感。而迪克西和我彼此深爱。
And I had a lot of people, a lot of people come to me telling me that, oh, I went through the same thing and here's what you're going to feel or here's what you're going to experience. And it was very well meaning. And I didn't mind it, but I found it, it was never true. One example, a lot of people, parents who lost children said, you're going to live with the guilt forever, which is not something you should say to anybody, but it's like they were living with guilt about something in their relationship with their child. And Dixie and I loved each other.
我的意思是，她被抚养得很好，她也被深爱着。没有什么人可以去怨恨或愤怒，也没有什么需要感到内疚的。所以，既然我们没有内疚和愤怒这种有毒的情绪，那就意味着，对我们而言，这只是一种纯粹的悲伤。但我意识到的更广泛的事情是：不要去寻找他人，不要强行在那些经历过同样事情的人身上套入一种虚假的相似性认同，因为这一切都完全取决于具体的情况。你将不得不独自度过属于你的这段独特旅程。
I mean, it was just, she was very well-parented and she was very loved. And there was no one to be angry at or angry and nothing to be guilty about. So the fact that we didn't have these toxic emotions of guilt and anger meant that it was just, in our case, it was a kind of pure sadness. But the broader thing I realized was don't go looking for people, don't force a kind of pretend similarity identity with other people who've gone through the same thing because it's so particular to the circumstances. You're going to have to kind of work through your particular journey on your own.
你没有地图。你必须挥舞着大砍刀，独自一人在丛林的一侧披荆斩棘走到另一侧。我的意思是，人们可能不想听到这个，但我就是这么想的。另一件事是，你知道这是一种什么样的体验，我的意思是，这真的是，我一生中从未有过这样的经历。它是如此令人不安、心碎、精疲力竭且让人迷失方向，我花了很长时间才弄清楚为什么我每天都觉得那么累——到底是怎么回事？
You don't have a map. You've got to get from one side of the jungle to the other side of the jungle. You have to pick your path with machete by yourself. And I mean, people may not want to hear that, but that's how I've come to think about it. The other thing was, you know what it's been, I mean, it is, I've never had any experience like this in my life. It's just, it's so disturbing and upsetting and so exhausting and disorienting, and it took me a while to figure out why I felt so tired every day, like what is going on there?
为什么我会这么，你知道的，为什么我记不住我的钥匙放在哪儿了？我意识到我的大脑已经默认了一种现实，而且我认为你的大脑就是这样运作的，它默认了一种现实，就像我把未来视为理所当然，甚至都没有去思考那个未来究竟是什么样的。而现在我必须重写那个，我的大脑必须重写那种现实——在一个没有迪克西·刘易斯的生活中。它一直在一条轨道上忙于做这件事，就像背景音乐一样无时无刻不在嗡嗡作响，尤其是最初的三四个月。
Why am I so, you know, why can't I remember where my keys are? And I realized that my mind was, had just presumed, and I think this is how your mind works, it presumes a reality, like I was taking for granted a future without even thinking about what that future was. And now I had to rewrite that, my brain had to rewrite that reality without living Dixie Lewis in it. And it was busy doing that on one track, like humming in the background all the time, especially the first three or four months.
这种感觉越来越少，就像现实已经开始——大脑已经开始意识到我不会再拥有她了，因此，我发现自己每天都更能找回自我。但这就好像，在认知层面，我没见过任何人这样描述过，但我心想，这就是，这就是正在发生的事情，也就是我正在试图，我正在试图打破一个故事并重新构建它，因为这个故事刚刚——我们刚刚失去了主角。但这真的是，太不寻常了。我告诉你另一件事，我的意思是，这，我不想用这个主题来烦你，
It's doing it less and less, like the reality has started to sort of, the brain has sort of like figured out that I'm not going to have her, and as a result, I'm finding myself feel more myself every day. But it was like, the cognitive thing was, I hadn't any see anybody kind of describe this, but I thought like, that's what that's what's going on, is that I am trying to, I'm trying to break a story and remake it, because the story just, we just lost the main character. But it's, it's been extraordinary. I tell you the other thing is that, I mean, this is, I don't want to bore you with a subject,
最情绪化的时刻往往发生在人们坚持要陪伴在你身边的时候。就像是，你永远不知道，面对一个刚刚失去孩子的父母，你能说些什么呢？我的本能大概会是躲起来，因为我为失去孩子的朋友感到太难过了。我不知道。你做什么都无法让事情变好。我才不会出现在他们的门廊前去打扰他们。我想我的本能在经历这一切之前会是：离他们远点，因为我
the things that the most emotional moments came when people just insisted on being there. Like it is, you never know what, what do you say to someone whose child has just died? It is, my instinct probably would be to hide, like I feel so sad for my friend whose child has died. I don't know. There's nothing you can do to make it better. I'm not going to show up on their doorstep and bother them. I think my instinct, before I had this experience would have been leave them alone, because I
最令人情绪激动的时刻往往是人们坚持要陪伴在身边的时候。就像那样，你永远不知道，当一个人的孩子刚刚离世时，你该对他说什么？这确实是，我的本能可能选择躲起来，因为我对那个失去孩子的朋感到无比难过。我不知道。你做什么都无法让情况变好。我才不会出现在他们的门前去打扰他们。我想我的本能，在经历这件事之前，会是让他们静一静，因为我
don't know what to say. And there's nothing to say. I have, I give one example, you know, the writer Dave Eggers, wonderful writer, wonderful friend, wonderful, wonderful friend. He lives across the bay, Dixie Dot, I got the news in the morning, an hour later, he's sitting on my doorstep with food, he just went and bought food and he's crying. And he says, I'm not leaving, I'm not going to buy, I'm going to sit, I'm going to sit outside in my car and I'm not leaving.
不知道该说什么。也没什么好说的。我有，我举个例子，你知道，作家戴夫·埃格斯，一个很棒的作家，很棒的朋友，一个非常非常好的朋友。他住在海湾对岸，迪克西·多特，我早上听到这个消息，一个小时后，他带着食物坐在我的门廊上，他刚刚去买了食物，然后他在哭。他说，我不走，我不会买，我要坐着，我要坐在外面的车里，我不会离开。
And I would never have thought that would be something I wanted. In retrospect, it's like, it was, it was, it was just such a gift, just to feel that feeling of being connected, someone insisting that I'm, I can't help you, but I'm going to, I'm going to be there anyway. It's so interesting when you said that about like, because I think a lot of people feel that way about like, do I impose, do I not impose, nobody, nobody knows exactly what that person wants because that person isn't being vocal about what they want and they, they don't know what they want.
我绝不会想到那会是我想要的东西。回想起来，这就像是一个礼物，只是为了感受到那种被连接的感觉，有人坚持说我，我帮不上忙，但我还是要去，不管怎样我都要去。当你说到那个的时候太有趣了，因为我觉得很多人都有这种感觉，比如，我是不是打扰了，我是不是没打扰，没有人，没有人确切知道那个人想要什么，因为那个人并没有大声说出他们想要什么，而且他们，他们自己也不知道想要什么。
Yeah, exactly. They don't know what they want. What they want is love. That's all they want. And they don't, they don't, even if they don't know it. And I didn't know I, that's, that's what I wanted. And that Dave is a gift for living and feeling and he's just got a gift for being a human being and he taught me something in that moment.
对，没错。他们不知道自己想要什么。他们想要的是爱。这就是他们想要的全部。而且他们，他们不，即使他们自己不知道。我也不知道我，那就是我想要的。戴夫是生活和感受的天赋，他有一种做人的天赋，他在那个时刻教了我一些东西。
And it was like, force it, like you love this person, let him know, right? Let him know right there because, because the essence of loss is the feeling of the loss of love. And you got to insist that that emotion is going to be there for that person. And it still, it still moves me just thinking about like that. It's like a heroic act. Not an easy thing to do. It's not what you want to do.
就像是，去争取它，就像你爱这个人，让他知道，对吧？当场让他知道，因为，因为失去的本质就是失去爱的感觉。你必须坚持这种情感会为了那个人而存在。仅仅想到那个，我依然，依然很感动。这就像是一个英雄般的行为。这可不是件容易的事。这不是你想做的事。
Go sit on someone's front porch whose child has just been killed in the car crash, but you go do it. That I think I'm, I hope that I remember it for the rest of my life. I, Michael, that, that's, that's the most well articulated description of, of somebody's experience with loss that I've, I think I've ever heard and, and I don't look it, but I'm 51. So I've been around for a long time. I honestly, that, that was incredible, man.
去坐在某个孩子的汽车事故中刚刚丧生的家长的门廊上，但你还是去做了。我想我会，我希望我余生都能记住它。迈克尔，那，那，那是我听过的关于一个人经历失去的最清晰的表达，而且，我看起来不像，但我已经51岁了。所以我经历过很多事情。老实说，那，那真是太不可思议了，老兄。
It was really, really beautiful. What a really beautiful. Yeah. And so I'll, I'll never, ever forget that story actually. Yeah. It's incredible. It's inspiring. Yeah.
真的，真的很美妙。多么美妙啊。是的。所以，我永远，永远不会忘记那个故事。是的。这太不可思议了。太鼓舞人心了。是的。
And, and, you know, we and, and, and our listeners are not as, as fortunate as, as, as Dave and that we don't, we're not as close to you, but, but know that we would, we would like to be and we, we, we think about you and we are fans of yours. I'm sure any and all of us that heard about the tragedy immediately thought about you, your family, your wife, your other kids, and would hope that you would somehow in some miracle, get through it, come through the other side or take with it everything you possibly could to carry on Dixie and, and become an even stronger family and, and some odd way that probably only somebody like you and Tabitha could.
而且，而且，你知道，我们，以及，以及我们的听众没有像，像，像戴夫那样幸运，我们没有，我们没有你那么亲近，但是，但是要知道我们，我们很想这样，我们，我们想着你，我们是你的粉丝。我敢肯定任何听到这个悲剧的人都会立刻想到你、你的家人、你的妻子、你的其他孩子，并希望你能以某种奇迹，度过难关，挺过去，或者带着你能带走的一切继续前行，迪克西，并且，以某种只有像你和塔比莎这样的人才能做到的奇异方式，成为一个更加坚强的家庭。
So I was just so obviously thrilled to hear you say that, yes, you would come talk to us because we hadn't talked for since our that, that, that one discussion and, and I'm just so thrilled that you are back out talking with everyone and I'm sure writing again and thinking again and, and don't go keep coming because we're all incredible fans of yours and, and are thinking about you and your family and wishing you guys the best. Yeah. And what a, what a treat, what a, what a pleasure to meet you and sending you and your family so much love from us.
所以我听到你说你会来和我们谈话时，显然非常激动，因为自从我们那次，那次讨论之后，我们就没再谈过，而且，我很高兴你重新出来和大家交谈，我确信你又开始写作和思考了，而且，不要停，继续来，因为我们都是你狂热的粉丝，而且，都在想着你和你的家人，祝你们一切都好。是的。真是太棒了，真是太荣幸能见到你，代表我们向你和你的家人送去满满的爱。
And thank you so much. Incredible having you. Thank you so much. Thanks, pal. Thank you. All right. Our best to you and your family and patiently awaiting your next, your next country. Yeah, come on.
非常感谢。有你做客太棒了。非常感谢。谢谢，老兄。谢谢。好的。祝你和你的家人一切都好，我们正耐心地等待你的下一个，你的下一个国家。来吧。
Can we get advanced copies? Is that possible? Cause I always have to. An audio for Jason. Oh yeah. An audio for Jason. Jason is an audio. Yeah.
我们能拿到提前版吗？可能吗？因为我总是得。为杰森准备的音频。哦，是的。为杰森准备的音频。杰森是一个音频。是的。
I'll need you to read it to me. Thank you so much. Thank you, pal. I'm going to meet you and thank you for all of that. Beautiful. Take care. Bye. See ya.
我需要你读给我听。非常感谢。谢谢，老兄。我要去见你，谢谢你所做的一切。很美妙。保重。再见。回头见。
Bye, pal. Bye, bud. Well, that's a, that's the first time my, my eyes leaked on this podcast. Yeah. What a, what a, what a, what a man that was, I mean, that's an incredible, you know, it's such a relatable thing. I think so many people don't know what to do when there is loss or tragedy. They just don't know because so you end up just doing what you believe is right.
再见，老兄。再见，伙计。好吧，这是，这是我的眼睛在这个播客上第一次漏水。是的。这是一个，一个，一个什么样的人啊，我的意思是，这是一件不可思议的事，你知道，这是一件如此感同身受的事。我想很多人在面对失去或悲剧时都不知道该怎么做。他们只是不知道，所以你最终只会做你认为是正确的事。
And it sounds like Dave Eggers is, it just was a perfect kind of reaction. Yeah. And it's funny. It's like that, the thing you were saying about people saying you're going to have this and you're going to have that really, it occurred to me in the moment that it probably is so much more about that person and what they're feeling than it has nothing to do with him. That's right.
听起来戴夫·埃格斯，这正是一种完美的反应。是的。这很有趣。就像你说的那些关于人们说你会拥有这个你会拥有那个的话，我当时突然意识到，这可能更多是关于那个人以及他们的感受，而跟他说的一点关系都没有。没错。
It's all about their experience. That's right. And I'm not blaming them saying that that's how they're, they're continuing to, you know, evolve and move through that loss. And by doing that, they say, you're going to do this and you're going to do that. And, you know, when you meet those people in life, the people do it all the time when they sort of give you advice, but they'll tell you things like, and you're going to, this is going to happen.
这完全是关于他们自己的经历。没错。我并不是在责怪他们，说那是他们继续，你知道，演变并度过那种失去的方式。通过这样做，他们说，你会这样做，你会那样做。而且，你知道，当你在生活中遇到那些人时，人们总是会这么做，当他们给你一些建议时，但他们会告诉你一些事情，比如，你将会，这将会发生。
You're thinking, yeah, for you. Yeah. Well, what an incredibly amazing and thoughtful and just, you know, connected guy and how amazing was it for him to share that with us? That was pretty special. I have so much respect for that guy and, and he takes what he knows to do so well, which is form a thought and articulate it in a way that people can digest it and something is as complex as all of these emotions and challenges that he and his family are going through to
你在想，是的，对你来说是这样。好吧，这是一个多么令人难以置信的、体贴的、而且，你知道的，有共情力的人，他能和我们分享这些，是多么了不起的一件事？这真的很特别。我对这家伙有着极大的敬意，而且，他运用了他最擅长的能力，那就是形成一个想法并以人们能够消化它的方式表达出来，就像他和他的家人正在经历的所有这些复杂的情感和挑战，
share all that with us in the way that he did. That was pretty generous. The only thing for me today, I guess that I feel particularly bad about is the fact that I, I guess I flashed everybody and you guys all got to, to peak my unit. Jason, Jason, I feel like the last time you saw my privates was when we were on that camping trip and I woke up about this for a second. You're the, the shorts thing, the legs and, you know, okay, let's get, okay, let's take a look.
以他那样的方式与我们分享这一切。那真是太慷慨了。我今天唯一觉得，我想我特别糟糕的事情是，我，我想我向所有人曝光了，你们都看到了我的那个部位。杰森，杰森，我觉得你上次看到我的私密部位还是我们在那次露营旅行的时候，我醒来后想了这件事一秒钟。你，那个短裤的事情，腿，还有，好吧，让我们，好吧，让我们看一看。
How are you standing up now, everybody? Yeah, that's okay. Sit back down, please. They're not that bad. Thank you. Just go ahead. Are they not that short? No, you got good legs.
大家现在怎么都站起来了？好吧，没关系。请坐回原位。它们没那么糟。谢谢。继续吧。它们没那么短吗？不，你的腿很好看。
You got to show off the assets. I've got great. He does have good legs. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you. I've been, I've been lucky. My mom said that she married my dad because he had good legs.
你得展示一下资本。我有着极好的。他的腿确实好看。谢谢。是的。谢谢。我，我很幸运。我妈妈说她嫁给我爸爸是因为他有一双好腿。
Excellent. You know, I think I have noticed that your dad does. He's a nice slender, tall man, right? Very slender. Yeah. I'm better in wind, you know. High wind. I've got the shorter legs.
太棒了。你知道，我想我注意到了你爸爸确实有。他是一个身材匀称、高挑的男士，对吧？非常匀称。是的。我在大风天表现更好，你知道。大风。我的腿比较短。
They're still not bad in, in, in, in short pants. Your legs, I'm trying to think, I'm trying to think of your legs too. So, so listener, if you, if you, if you're wearing pants now, so basically everybody except Will, if you look down, your, your, your pants, where they hit your shins, it's kind of on the outside of your shins, not on the inside, it's on the outside. I've noticed that I've lost all the hair. I do too. My hands have been rubbing against my leg.
穿着短裤它们看起来也还行。你的腿，我在想，我也在想你的腿。所以，听众朋友们，如果你，如果你，如果你现在穿着裤子，基本上除了威尔之外的所有人，如果你往下看，你的裤子，它们落到你的小腿的位置，有点在你的小腿外侧，不在内侧，是在外侧。我注意到我所有的毛发都掉光了。我也是。我的手一直在我的腿上摩擦。
I, I have all kinds of hair on the inside of my shin, like from my knee to my ankle on the inside of both legs, but on the outside, nothing. Like I've, like I've shaved because I'm a, I'm a bike rider or something. You guys are getting old. That's what, oh, that's what happens. You see that thing with old men where they've got those like shiny legs and you're like, did that guy shave his legs? No.
我，我的小腿内侧有各种各样的毛，比如从膝盖到脚踝，两条腿的内侧都有，但在外侧，什么都没有。就像我，就像我刮过毛一样，因为我是一个，我是一个骑自行车的人什么的。你们都在变老。这就是，哦，这就是会发生的事情。你看到老年人那种光溜溜的腿时，你会想，那家伙刮腿毛了吗？不。
No. He just used a lot of moisturizer. You know, I was always wondering that. Hey, is this, are these shorts too high or anything? Oh no. Yeah. Uh-oh. Listener, Sean has his pants pulled up just underneath his breasts.
不。他只是用了大量的保湿霜。你知道，我一直很好奇这个。嘿，这个，这些短裤是不是太高了还是怎么的？哦，不。是的。噢哦。听众朋友们，肖恩把裤子拉到了胸部正下方。
Yeah. But I've been noticing as I get older, you know, I can go to the gym, I work out and do all this stuff, but I'm still able to maintain pretty good muscle on my bicep. Bicep. Smart. What? Smart. What?
是的。但我开始注意到随着我年龄的增长，你知道，我可以去健身房，我锻炼并做所有这些事情，但我仍然能够在我的二头肌上保持相当不错的肌肉。二头肌。聪明。什么？聪明。什么？
Smart. What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
聪明。什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？
What? What? What? What? What? What? SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob ARMJERV, Bennett Barbicow and Michael Granteri.
什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？SmartList是由Rob ARMJERV、Bennett Barbicow和Michael Granteri 100%有机手工制作的。
SmartList. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondryclass in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry App. Yep. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartList。我们的下一期节目将在两周后发布，你可以在你收听播客的任何地方收听，或者现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客或Wondry应用上订阅Wondryclass来提前收听并免除广告。是的。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。